ich verstehe nicht warum ich auf diesem
planet bin hallo leute ich jetzt wieder
eure x plane und willkommen zum
allerersten sommerloch in 2000 blieben
in 2017 sommerloch nummer in diesem jahr
wollte ich mal wieder ein bisschen
kreativ sein und hat mir ein paar neue
kategorien ausgedacht ich hoffe wie
gefallen euch und ich würde sagen wir
fliegen los ging am wochenende steht dir
gehen hahahaha am wochenende weiß mit
meiner guten freundin fifi auf den
karneval der kulturen und ich habe
natürlich vergessen mit zufällen
denn ich bin ein mit vorzeige youtuber
habe ich beides in verden gepostet und
jetzt bewundert
[Musik]
an den kopf sie werden glücklich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wann das tolle bäder und jetzt geht
schon weiter mit der nächsten kategorie
und zwar ist es noch der arbeiten ende
sommer hat in diesem moment wollte so
hackfleisch aber weil ich kein fleisch
mehr
ich konnte die gitarre fleisch nehmen
aber dann wieder die ganzen gleich ja
gar kein hackfleisch ist
was habe ich denn da bekommt eine neue
kategorie live am boxring vor der kamera
christina staffel werde es gleich
erfahren dafür in kleinen mini platz
nein das ist super cool und zwar möchte
auch die kokosnuss creme torte icarly
nachmachen und dafür brauche ich diese
trainieren einging wie ein coconut green
power und amerikanische rezepte werden
immer mid caps angezeigt an ich dachte
bevor ich mich jetzt so dumm und dämlich
messe hole ich mir einfach weil ich
möchte ja erst mal vielleicht ein
amerikanisches paar machen und da kannst
du dann immer wie größen bestimmt das
ist auf jeden fall ein sommerkleid und
mit mein gott cups ist einfach gerade
die beste überleitung wenn mein erstes
sommer hat geht an die medien verkaufen
und so habe ich mit euch über bhs
spricht und versteht ihr jetzt cup bitte
euch nämlich vom ganzen herzen bitte
bitte hört auf diese durchsichtigen
träger zu tragen sind nämlich überhaupt
nicht durchsichtig und wenn man die
träger sieht dann tragt doch lieber ein
bh der hab ich dazu passt auch besser
aktive ich hab aber letztens noch eine
alternative gesehen und zwar pläne wie
hart so sehen die aus ich weiß nicht ob
sie funktioniert ich habe mir noch kein
geholt falls ihre pläne gehabt
verratet doch mal sind die gut kann man
die tragen wir nicht irgendwann einfach
weg
kennt ihr dafür die einkaufen seiten so
ein oberteil und denke wow das ist total
hübsch ich finde das wunderschön aber
wie zur hölle soll man das tragen ohne
dass man den bh vorne hinten links
rechts überall sieht und dass sie die
meisten punkte aus
also klebl hat die revolution für die
frau von heute machen wir lieber weiter
geschichten aus der youtube welt da ich
absolut keine lust über bewegung zu
sprechen lassen doch mal schauen welche
youtuber ein buch herausgebracht hat
wenn ich ein richtiger youtuber werden
möchte muss ich habe auch ein buch
ausbringen habt ihr irgendwelche
vorschläge
leichter hätten auch den main keiner man
halte die reform wie werde ich nur halb
so gut wie italien oder wie wär's zum
krimi thriller der tagebuch dieb oder
bringen wechselte buch aus
ich verstehe nicht warum ich auf diesem
planet bin aber ich wollte mich lieber
nicht darüber lustig machen wenn am ende
soziale kompass informierung war das
etwa eine ankündigung eine geschichte
gibt es nicht ansprechen muss titels den
alltag weiter warum machen alle menschen
zu überbieten war ganz kurz davor mir
einzukaufen weil ich in meinem spe die
an der kasse gesehen habe aber ich
dachte mir nein das mache ich mit du
hast pokémon go mitgemacht
das reicht lieber zu meinem liebling
mein aktueller lieblingssong wurde mir
auf 'youtube' vorgeschlagen und fragen
das neue lied von bvdm neuer alter
versteht weiß nicht warum ich habe
diesen traum von der ersten sekunde an
so hart gefeiert und kann in jeden fall
drauf und runter hören und er wird mir
nicht langweilig und ich finde dieser
dvd nf der flut so gut und so flog nur
er und das klingt total uncool wenn ich
das sage an alle helfer waren raus und
entschuldigung ich werde mich jetzt
wieder
es wird zeit für meine favoriten
mein favorit ist cherry blossom tonic
und verbindet man tonic water ja
üblicherweise führt sind onic aber ich
mache mir den in weißwein rhein unter
schmidt wirklich vorzüglich kein alkohol
unter 85 und ganz vorsichtig mit alkohol
alkohol kann ganz viel kaputt machen
immer mit vorsicht genießen jap
bildungsauftrag erfüllt mein zweiter
favorit ist dieses kleine wunderliche
teil und war das eine lautsprecherbox du
dir in die dusche hängen kann und wie
kann nach werden und das stört sie nicht
da geht die musik einfach weiter
und da finde ich klasse wenn ich unter
der dusche bin dann höre ich nämlich
super gerne musik aber das problem dass
manche von super leise und manche super
laut sind und dann kann man mal
lautstärke nicht regeln weil man halt
gerade
was ist und mit dem ding geht das finde
ich super klasse und mein dritter
favorit ist thermalwasser und fragt ihr
euch bald aber warum thermalwasser weil
das in firma super praktisch ist das ist
was er hier drin also thermalwasser und
dann wenn ihr zu warmes sprühen zu dein
gewicht an oder deine arme deinen körper
alles kosten möchte und dann bist du
richtig schön abgekühlt und das finde
ich toll
sogar noch ein bisschen entzündung kommt
also perfekt wie immer findet ihr unten
in der infobox keine effekt links ist
die produkte schon selber suchen
aktuelle sachen zu denen ich etwas sagen
will auch mit keinen interessiert hat
überlegt was ich zu den ganzen
terroranschlägen sagen könnte aber ganz
ehrlich mir fehlen dazu wirklich die
worte ich glaube nicht dass ich sagen
könnte würde wirklich das aussprechen
was ich meine oder was ich fühle dazu
dafür könnte ich aber euch von dem
konzert erzählen von dem langlauf
manchester konzert das ich gesehen hat
von adriana grande und miley cyrus war
star pharell williams
katy perry und sie haben alle ein
konzert gemacht in manchester zu gunsten
der familien und angehörigen der opfer
und die manchester angriff grund das
fand ich super schön also die ganze show
war einfach bei jedem song hast du
wirklich hast du überlebst gefühlt und
verteidige botschaft drauf zu tragen hey
wir verstecken uns nicht wir sind
dagegen
wir finden liebe toll wir finden
zusammenhalt toll und wir halten alle
zusammen und das fand sie einfach super
ja und mehr gibt es dazu eigentlich
nicht zu sagen der nächste punkt auf
unseren ist machen wir ganz besonderen
spaß und zwar wieder kind sein
für die heutige wurde wieder kind sein
gibt doping code culum drauf also muss
das cool sein ich hab diese teil als
kind geliebt
gibt dem video einen daumen wenn ihr in
pocking crazy lollis auch so gerne mögen
das prinzip ist ganz einfach ihr nutzt
den lonnie an und dann gebt ihr ihnen
die saure zeug und ihr könnt ihr das
abspecken so laut leg kommen wir nun zu
der frage ich habe ich öfter gefragt
welche geschmacksrichtung es in diesem
sommer auch noch geben sollte und das
sind eure antworten
dusan geschmack lecker mit ganz viel web
backum drauf höhner geschmack und dann
brauchte dann statt einer kirche eine
ganze kette zu loben drauf habt eine
genauso gute idee pizza geschmack und
dann könnte man der stadt der waffel für
pizzateig waffel machen
oh mein gott was muss ich unbedingt mal
ausprobieren ob wir das mekka pizza
waffeln und eis mit butter biergeschmack
das wäre der chip für alle harry potter
fans noch eine gute perspektive
wie wäre es denn wenn sie diesen sommer
mal statt spaghetti eis zwischen nudeln
mit huhn essen wird mit dem witz bin
oben brauchen während du was ist klar
dass die ganze zweite sultans gesicht
perfekt klappt wie letzter
geschmacksrichtung wird uns allen am
besten schmecken kofi fehlkauf cockpit
coffees ich habe und natürlich hat das
sommerloch gefallen und zum schluss gibt
es jetzt noch die lebensweisheit der
woche rede mal nicht so als ob du einen
werbespot wärst hier kommt ihr zur
sommerloch playlist und dort findet ihr
mein letztes video und da oben könnt ihr
mich noch abonnieren
dann verpasst ihr kein neues video und
dann könnt ihr in der schule oder bei
der arbeit erzählen ich verpasse kein
neues video von mal wanne
dann werden die euch fragen wer diesmal
wanne tucson juni